why am I talking about contract and why
why my dad made that up that version the
reason is this there is something which
unifies yes Western saw and Islamic
thought and it is the idea of contract
it is the idea of contract the Quran
says er you a lady named Oh Bulbul are
quotes o you who believe
to fill the contracts and in liberal
theory one of the underpinning things is
God make sure that you fulfill the
contract because it's so obvious that
chaos would ensue listen carefully chaos
would ensue if contracts are not abided
by imagine you have peace treaties
between countries and they're revoked
straight away because contracts are not
respected contracts are important on
everyone's world view on our world view
and on their world view why is that
important because imagine listen
carefully what is the consequence
according to them of rupturing a
contract yeah you can have anarchy but
usually the law has in place legal
consequences yes if the law hasn't quit
and place legal consequences which can
range from prison sentence to finding to
death in the case of treason the idea
that there should be a consequence
attached to a severing of a contract is
universally understood almost except
with anarchists and other people right I
imagine this imagine we as human beings
are severing a contract with the
ultimate source of protection wait a
minute stay that one more time I don't
know how you made that diversion and you
came back and what you're talking about
the ultimate source of protection we
believe is Allah he provides the
ultimate source of protection so isn't
it the same logic to suppose to
postulate to submit to say
if you break the contract that was
initially in place some it's up and that
you agreed upon and the prime model
sales if you sell that contract there
should be a consequence and it's within
the rights of the source of protection
to remove that protection from you
that's why the question that's usually
postulated in these discussions is if
God is so merciful then why does hell
exists why is he putting the people in
the Hellfire
what kind of merciful God is that he
putting their people in the Hellfire
what kind of Justice is that the
Hellfire is an ultimate manifestation of
the removal of a large protection from
humans see the whole time
the Hellfire is an ultimate
manifestation of the removal of a large
protection from human beings and since
we agree on the premise that's
consequentially justifiable to say that
protection should no longer be afforded
to those who serve Allah contracts then
what more contracts more problematic to
sever than the one who is providing for
you in all aspects and domains and
spheres of life the answer to that
question is the people that don't
understand the Hellfire and the
punishment therein are those same people
that don't understand the severity of
the contract and they have agreed to and
that they were reminded off
in this world so you see it all makes
sense now
but someone may argue someone may argue
and say but hold on no problem I
understand this concept I understand yes
that if you sever the contract there
should be consequences
yeah if you sever the contract there
should be consequences from this
perspective God is within his rights to
give you those consequences
so what then about proportionality for
instance if someone was a Kaffir for
this believer someone who severed the
contract because ways it is believer at
this believer if someone kasev literally
means kuffara from the farmer the farmer
because he's literally covering the
truth like the seeds you coat it with
soil and the truth you're covering it
with falsehood and that is the ultimate
manifestation of the severing of the
contract well the question of
proportionality will come into play
because they'll say ok if they were
disbelievers for three years or five
years or ten years or twenty years then
why should they be in the Hellfire
forever
and this is a lack of proportionality
yes this is a lack of proportionality
well we say to that who told you that
times did all be treated equally and
sins should be connected to time
inextricably let me give an example and
this brother of mine codable andalusi we
were discussing this he was giving me
these pointers was a really good example
he gave I like to give him credit for
that he said for example if someone
takes out a knife and he stabs someone
goes straight for the jugular and kills
the person in three
seconds yes if someone does that in
three seconds should they be punished
for three seconds on this logic they
should be why not three seconds the only
were transgressing for three seconds so
go into prison for three seconds or do
this we'll go to the Hellfire for three
seconds no clearly there's a problem
with equating time here so the idea is
or the association of partners with
Allah is valued so epistemic Lehi and
the ranking of crimes because is the
ultimate it is the ultimate rupturing of
the most important contracts by even
doing it for one second even believing
in that and doing it for one second it's
conceivable for one second two seconds
five seconds and you die upon it and
although your last five seconds that you
will be in eternal punishment in the
Hellfire and that is logically
rationally justifiable on both
worldviews because to understand Allah
and for hate we must understand shift
and how dark and horrible and evil and
grotesque and disgusting this crime is
out there someone redirects their
veneration
they love their or their hope their
faith
from the one who is offering all sorts
of health and also says a protection
from fear who is a loss of a Noah to
Allah this is the most problematic and
egregious and the most vile of crimes
any human being could do well success
was the murder was the rape there's
nothing worse than that
why is murder on because it's an
ultimate violation of someone's right to
life why is rape run because it's an
ultimate violation of a man or a woman's
right to dignity and to decision-making
in sexual intercourse so why is
wrong because it's an ultimate
redirection it's an ultimate redirection
of all of the attitudes the beliefs and
the actions that should be positions to
the one who allows them to be positioned
to anything in the first place to other
than him it's the worst kind of
oppression shirk is the worst kind of
oppression